foreign
The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time the
game's solely responsible for getting me
hooked on the Zelda series all the way
back in the good old 90s it's one of
those landmark games whose impact on the
industry can still be felt today Paving
the way for the future of the action
adventure genre of course the game has
since been surpassed everyone banded
here sorry for the intrusion but are we
talking about my favorite and
objectively the best Zelda game ever
made Ocarina of Time uh yeah yeah well I
mean personally I prefer Majora's Mask
but you know I'm gonna pretend like I
didn't hear that anyway as maze man here
stated correctly Ocarina of Time was a
milestone not just for the future of the
Zelda series itself but the video game
industry as a whole most will point to
gameplay aspects of it you know Z
targeting Auto jumping context sensitive
controls yada yada but Ocarina of Time
did so much more for the series than
just game design it also gave the world
of Hyrule a much deeper story and we're
not just talking about dialogue and
cutscenes but other storytelling purely
through the environment of course many
Zelda games have since followed suit and
breath of the wild took the aspect of
environmental storytelling to the
extreme but in large part Ocarina of
Time is the one that started it in
particular when it came to dungeons sure
the older games had plenty of dungeons
too but they were just kind of there
just as a challenge for the player to
overcome and in most cases it's never
really explained why these structures
exist or what their purpose was in
Ocarina of Time however dungeons finally
became something more than that here
there was a story hidden behind the
architecture ready to be discovered and
theorized about it doesn't beat you over
the head with it and they can still be
enjoyed as just a challenge and nothing
more but those who enjoy going down the
rabbit holes may find subtle Clues as to
what these places are or used to be the
interesting stuff for sure but what does
it have to do with me oh well my friend
as you may have heard I recently kicked
off a new series of videos where I
covered the lore behind every dungeon
from various Zelda titles so how's about
you and I go on a little dungeon expert
Edition together and you can help split
the effort 50 50. I'm sure I guess
magnificent oh uh can I have the Shadow
Temple yes you can have the Shadow
Temple nice alright then let's get
started
[Music]
ah yes the Deku Tree a true Zelda
Classic if there ever was one of course
in terms of gameplay it's nothing to
really write home about I mean it
features some of the most basic puzzles
in the series and you can easily Breeze
through it in under 20 minutes or so
even on a first playthrough but keep in
mind that this was the first 3D Zelda
dungeon ever conceived and navigating a
space in three dimensions was still a
bit of a novel concept at the time yes
even something as simple as opening
doors back in the old days you just
walked into a door and Pat a bang bad
boom you're in another room but now you
have to press a button I don't know what
to do but what about the lore behind
this place well I mean it's inside of
the Deku Tree no mystery there but
there's definitely some ambiguity in
history here the origin of the Deku Tree
is in large part left up to the
imagination of the player we know he's a
guardian Spirit one of many seen across
the series and that he's been around for
a very long time popping up in various
places across Zelda chronology all the
way up to breath of the wild which as
many of you know takes place somewhere
at the end of the timeline that said
Ocarina of Time is his first appearance
both in real life as well as in Universe
has no game taking place before Ocarina
features the Deku Tree as we know it
there is however a potentially distant
relative to be found in Skyward Sword
the very first Adventure in the
chronology in the Faron Woods area
there's a gigantic tree towering over
the entire Forest aptly named The Great
tree unsurprisingly many suspect that
this is the great Deku Tree in its
primordial form so to speak before he
became a sentient being who watches over
the forest and its inhabitants its size
and location roughly match that of the
great Deku Tree and just like the forest
Guardian from Ocarina of Time the great
tree is hollow on the inside there's a
central chamber with a similar looking
pattern that spirals upwards as well as
a tunnel leading to a basement like
space below the root system of the gray
tree it's kind of crazy to think that
this could very well be the same place
the hero of time would be put to the
test many ages later so what about the
dungeon part of him I mean it's made
obvious that the Deku Tree has always
been Hollow on the inside but what's up
with all the architecture you know the
doors ladders torches and all these
other Contraptions and not to mention
the monster infestation it's explained
that right before the start of Link's
Adventure Ganondorf himself actually
paid a visit to the Deku Tree in person
his goal was to press the guardian of
the forest into giving him the Kokiri
Emerald one of three spiritual Stones
needed to open the door to the sacred
realm and claim the Triforce when the
Deku Tree refused Ganondorf placed a
curse on him out of spite not cool
Ganondorf not cool at all agreed poor
Deku Tree by the time link is summoned
to meet the forest Guardian the curse
has allegedly been festering inside him
for quite some time link is then tasked
with breaking the curse by venturing
inside as a way to test his wisdom and
courage to see if he is ready to face
the dangers ahead and ultimately save
Hyrule now you would think that this
explains the various monsters roaming
around the tree's innards but actually
it doesn't well not entirely anyway
while there are some monsters who could
be considered responsible for the slow
decline line of the Deku tree's Health
like the Goma who are described as
parasitic there are various creatures
here who don't seem to have anything to
do with the curse most notably the Deku
scrubs one strange detail is that for
some reason the scrubs refer to Goma as
their Queen which is kind of odd when
you think about it since they're not
even remotely the same species we do
find creatures who are of the same
species and even share the same name a
larval State version of Goma who would
no doubt grow to the same size if given
enough time it makes you wonder whether
or not the Goma appeared after the curse
was casted or if they've always lived
here undisturbed in that ganondorf's
curse either made them more parasitic
and destructive to their environment or
may even share no connection to the
curse at all the Deku Tree doesn't
exactly do a good job at explaining why
he's dying all he says is that the curse
is sapping his power but anyway after
beating the dungeon it's also revealed
that while Link's efforts to break the
curse were Valiant the fate of the great
Deku Tree was already sealed and he knew
this so as stated before it really was
all just a test for the hero to prove
himself as opposed to an attempt save
the giant guardian's Life As for the
interior design of the tree itself there
are a few different options as to why it
looks the way it does because it's a
video game level made for humans by
humans for the sole purpose of
entertainment no well okay yeah but come
on man this is a Zelda Theory Let's
ignore the cold-hearted reality for a
moment here anyway the most obvious
answer would be that since it was a test
for the hero it is just that a trial
conceived by the forest Guardian perhaps
built by the Deku scrubs or the Kokiri
so that one day The Chosen hero would be
able to enter and prove his worthiness a
solid enough explanation though that is
some impressive bit of foresight on the
side of the Deku Tree but whatever I
mean he is an ancient Spirit Guardian I
guess another option as to why the Deku
trees insides have man-made features to
them is that it served as a kind of
shelter a place for the beings of the
forest to retreat to in case the forest
would ever come under siege even for
Deku scrubs apparently so clearly tree
man over here doesn't discriminate in
breath of the wild we can see a similar
occurrence where some of the four
Spirits have made a home inside inside
the Deku Tree setting up shops and
living spaces and it makes sense the
Deku Tree is a being who provides safety
and comfort he's a guardian who protects
the forest and its children from the
dangers lurking outside
[Music]
Jabo jabo's belly perhaps better known
as the grossest dungeon in Zelda history
again no mystery in regards to what this
place is it's the insides of Lord
jabu-jabu the only fish in history to
receive lordship as far as I'm aware and
one with some major digestive problems
like I said grossest Zelda dungeon ever
the situation surrounding jabu-jabu is
actually quite similar to that of the
Deku Tree he's a guardian in this case
of the Zora who got cursed by Ganondorf
after the Zora King refused to hand over
their spiritual Stone the Zora Sapphire
here too the curse takes on the form of
a kind of illness something which is
slowly festering and corrupting the
Creature from the inside if you pay
close attention you can even hear that
jabu's heartbeat is integrated into the
music track and purposely sounds
irregular and offbeat
foreign
Princess Ruto explains that she tends to
jabu-jabu on a regular basis and as such
the guardian and her share a close Bond
but that one day presumably after he was
cursed jabu-jabu swallowed the princess
hole along with her most treasured
belonging the Zora Sapphire the same one
Ganondorf was trying to obtain from the
Zora King now it may seem that Ruto
getting munched up by her own fish God
was a one-time anomaly caused by the
sickness It suffers from but Ruto
mentions that she's actually been
venturing inside jabu's big old belly
ever since she was little for what
reason we don't know and is perhaps best
left unexplained the only difference is
that this time the inside of jabu-jabu
has become a lot more hazardous Ruto
mentions the sudden appearance of
electric jellyfish as well as strange
holes which allegedly weren't there
before a clear indication that
ganondorf's death curse is slowly eating
away at the Zora Guardian from within
which can I just say is one of the most
disturbing Fates I could possibly
imagine yeah man Ganondorf doesn't mess
around so after traversing the dungeon's
death link is similarly faced with a
giant parasitic creature and the alleged
Source behind jabu-jabu suffering the
bioelectric anemone anemone baronade no
doubt named after the real life cm in
Menominee some of which are parasitic to
other marine life however just like the
great Deku Tree jabu jabu's death may
have been imminent as well despite
Link's best efforts the reason being is
that when link travels seven years into
the future the Zora Guardian is nowhere
to be found it's actually one of the
more famous mysteries in Ocarina of Time
and one which a lot of people have
speculated about over the years some
think he may have survived and was
relocated somewhere else others say he
probably died either from the curse or
the rapid changing climate in and around
Zora's domain unfortunately nozora ever
explains his absence or when and why he
disappeared it is true that a creature
similar to jabu-jabu named jaboon makes
an appearance in the Wind Waker which
takes place in the same timeline but
aside from the similar name it's hard to
say if they are actually related by
blood in any way if they are there is a
chance that jabu-jabu did survive the
curse and the freezing of the domain but
if they are not related then perhaps
jabun was already born before the curse
was placed on jabu-jabu I'd say that he
most likely died while link was in
purgatory for seven years the fact that
the Deku Tree still wasn't able to
survive the curse despite the
eradication of Goma doesn't bode well
for jabujabu I mean after all they are
similar in stature that is to say
Guardian Spirits it's also worth
mentioning that even after destroying
baronade the inside of jabu-jabu doesn't
change or heal the strange holes in
electric jellyfish are still everywhere
whatever happened to jabu-jabu during
and after the events of Ocarina of Time
others like him have picked up the torch
in the future however his disappearance
from the adult timeline will likely
remain one of Ocarina of time's many
inexplicable Mysteries
the fire temple everyone's not favorite
but also not least favorite Zelda
dungeon generally speaking of course
it's one of those dungeons that isn't
really talked about all that much
compared to some of the others and I can
see why it doesn't have the memorable
atmosphere or sense of mystery I say the
forest or Shadow Temple it doesn't have
the killer soundtrack of the spirit
Temple nor does it have the infamous
reputation of the water temple as gen Z
would say it's kind of mid the only
things that really stand out about the
fire temple are the ICONic final boss
because you know who doesn't enjoy
fighting a giant dragon and of course
the famous controversy surrounding the
Temple's original music track which
includes recordings of actual
translatable Islamic chants which
Nintendo was unaware of at the time
foreign
[Music]
as such the music was preemptively
changed and the original score now
exists only in the 1.0 and 1.1 builds of
the game although the change is
perfectly understandable the inclusion
of chanting was actually quite fitting
similar to the water and spirit Temple
the fire temple was considered to have
been a place of worship for the gorons
before it was corrupted by Ganondorf as
evident from the many altars and statues
present here there's also a few hints
and remnants of that of a prison like
the holding cells that housed some of
the captured gorons but it's unclear if
these were always here or if they were
constructed after the temple was already
corrupted we don't know much about the
fire Temple's construction but it
possibly had something to do with the
famous Goron Legend darunia Sun speaks
of the story of an unnamed Goron hero
who single-handedly defeated an ancient
fire dragon using a giant hammer a
battle that saved the Goron race from
Extinction the current day leader of the
gorons darunia is even said to be a
descendant of said hero needless to say
this was a major historical event in
Goron culture and could have been the
Catalyst for the construction of the
fire temple in the distant past both as
a way to commemorate the Goron hero of
old as well as to enshrine the final
resting place of their deceased
adversary volvagia even the legendary
Hammer used to defeat the dragon is
still kept on an altar deep inside the
temple after ganondorf's rise to power
in Hyrule he not only corrupted the fire
temple but the self-proclaimed King of
Evil resurrected the ancient dragon to
punish and eradicate the gorons for
defying him the sad part about the story
is that when link arrives at the fire
temple darunia himself decides to face
volvagia alone in order to buy links
some time to free his imprisoned people
however as he himself states he does not
possess the legendary Hammer yet still
decides to go in despite the odds I'm
sure you can tell where we're going with
this but there's long since been a
debate on whether or not the sages are
actually dead or not and darunia's
heroic sacrifice is often used as
evidence that they very well could be as
opposed to the other sages whose fate is
kept a bit more ambiguous in the case of
darunia it's pretty evident as to what
happened to him I mean we see him
entering volvagia's Lair all by himself
yet we never see him come out out alive
and by the time link follows suit
volvagia is still there ready to rock
and roll meanwhile darunia is nowhere to
be found the fire temple may not be the
most popular or most memorable dungeon
in Ocarina of Time but it definitely
features an engaging story a story of
sacrifice of bravery and an ancient evil
brought back from the afterlife as one
of the more iconic Final Bosses in the
series
[Music]
oh boy here we go this Shadow Temple or
as I like to call it the E for everyone
dungeon yeah Nintendo definitely wasn't
holding back with this one now it's not
necessarily the most popular dungeon
when it comes to gameplay in part due to
its extreme linearity but it is one of
the most talked about locations when it
comes to lore it fully Embraces the
darker and more mature side of the
series but does so in a way that most of
it is left up to the imagination of the
player we learned that prior to the
events of Ocarina of Time Hyrule was
embroiled in a Fierce and gruesome Civil
War the same war that made link an
orphan killing his father and forcing
his mortally wounded mother to leave the
boy in the care of the great Deku Tree
before she herself passed away as well
the hyrulean Civil War as it's called
would ultimately decide which of the
four prominent races would gain control
over the land of Hyrule which after an
era of Bloodshed the hylians ended up
winning with the remaining factions
swearing loyalty to the Hylian royal
family when Link's Adventure Starts the
war has only been resolved for a few
years and the Shadow Temple is a remnant
of some of the Hidden crew that took
place at the time it was built by the
sheikah a tribe who has long served the
royal family of Hyrule both in peacetime
as well as during the war it's revealed
that they served as a sort of secret
police force who operated from the
Shadows serving as Royal bodyguards
assassinating enemies of the king as
well as taking care of prisoners of War
locking them up and even resorting to
torture to get information until
eventually disposing of them in ways
that are perhaps better left imagined of
course this wasn't exactly something the
royal family wanted the world to see and
was preferably kept from the history
books and so below the depths of
kakuriko Village home of the sheikah at
the time of the war the Shadow Temple
was used to obscure these acts of
Cruelty and keep them out of sight from
the public eye this place represents one
of the darkest depths Nintendo has ever
dared to go with their storytelling even
if it is hidden under the surface both
literally and figuratively interestingly
enough although the Shadow Temple is one
of the more popular dungeons to theorize
about in many respects it has the most
fleshed out backstory out of all five
temples present in Ocarina of Time we
know exactly what this place is and the
purpose it once served a secret wartime
prison and torture site for enemies of
Hyrule that isn't to say that there are
no Mysteries left to unravel about the
Shadow Temple though there's the
mysterious floating ship that carries
its passengers across a foggy Chasm for
example very reminiscent of the undead
fairy man who carries Souls across the
river sticks we still don't know for
sure why it's here or what it was used
for though there are plenty of theories
about it of course another interesting
feature are the many statues of what
seem to be blind rats or mice perhaps a
reference to the act of turning a blind
eye to the atrocities committed on
behalf of the royal family it's a
central theme all throughout the Shadow
Temple the aspect of the Unseen Hidden
Truths and events taking place in the
shadows this is exemplified by the lens
of Truth also known as The Eye of Truth
a magic artifact capable of peering
through and revealing the unseen even
the Insignia of the shika itself is
representative of this as well as the
symbol on the door of the Shadow Temple
of an eye in three stages open open half
open and close and of course we can't
talk about the Shadow Temple without
also mentioning Bongo Bongo you know
just another piece of nightmare fuel
strike from the minds of the Zelda team
We're Not Gonna dive into the possible
identity of Bongo Bongo as there are so
many theories about it it would take
ages to get through all of them besides
I happen to have already made a video
that focuses specifically on the bosses
of Ocarina of Time but a general
consensus is that he could have been one
of the prisoners who was maimed and
killed in the Shadow Temple by the
sheikah or perhaps the concoction of
many of them turning them or him into a
monstrous evil spirit being hell-bent on
causing destruction mainly due to his
appearance which is that of a torso with
a missing head and amputated hands with
all that said it's possible that the
Shadow Temple once served a different
purpose before it was repurposed into a
torture Prison from Hell perhaps just
like some of the other temples it was
once a place of worship or maybe
something akin to a mausoleum a place
where the dead were laid to rest which
would explain the floating ship as it
could have been used for a sort of
soul-fearing ritual it's not even clear
if ganondorf's influence had anything to
do with the current state of the Shadow
Temple though his corruption has spread
on a Country-Wide scale it's arguable if
the Shadow Temple had any need of an
outside force to corrupt it the history
of this place alone seems to have been
perfectly capable of causing a
Corruption of its own and some areas in
and around kakarika were already
Infested by the undead long before
ganondorf's power grab with the Shadow
Temple Nintendo truly walked the line
between a relatively innocent and
classic fantasy story and straight up
horror and it's unlikely that we'll ever
see something even close to it in the
meantime though it'll remain a hidden
part of hyrule's bloody history and
theories about it will no doubt continue
to be discussed for many years to come
and that my friends concludes this part
of the lore behind the dungeons in
Ocarina of Time be sure to let us know
your thoughts and theories on some of
these locations down in the comments and
of course go and check out the other
half on my friend Bandit's Channel which
covers the dangers Cavern the forest
water and spirit Temple anyway thank you
for the collaboration good sir anytime
Mr Mays you you know me I hear the words
occurring of time and I jump in head
first no matter whose Channel or video
it is so um yeah thanks for uh yeah
thanks for having me I had a lot of fun
and I'm so grateful for your audience
for putting up with me as well if you
guys watching are interested in the
other dungeons like Mr May said they are
live right now over on my channel so hey
maybe see you there Bandit away
and with that I bid you all farewell and
I hope you have a great week a special
thanks to Bandit games to my mods and of
course my patreons and channel members I
hope to see you all in the next video
this is Don signing off and have a good
one
foreign
[Music]
[Music]